okay youtube is changing
how voting down works on videos instead
of you seeing a count of all the votes
down when you click the vote down button
only the creator is going to see that
vote down and they want to do this to
make the platform more respectful and to
support emerging founders who are
getting hit with swarms of people
who will vote down their content not
just because they don't like it but
i guess there's some insinuation here
that it's a bullying or a coordinated
attack
who knows we live in very charged times
this comes at the same time
that instagram and facebook starting
allowing users to hide the number of
likes
on their own posts so i saw this myself
on instagram was like hey do you want to
show likes or not show likes do you want
to let your only your friends comment so
i think this has to do with giving
people more power uh and not making them
feel as bad when they use services so on
instagram people feel bad about
themselves and the number of likes they
get and you know maybe that affects
people in the body dysmorphia area
according to the research because it's a
very visual medium on
youtube you have people performing and
talking like i am right now
and the votes down is um you know for a
performer i i guess can make them feel
very bad and maybe they will not want
to
produce more content which is a problem
for youtube so youtube i think has a
concern about
uh people you know maybe not becoming
creators this is a difficult argument
here according to the verge instagram's
adam mossari stated that hiding likes
quote didn't actually change nearly as
much about how people felt
or how much they used the experience as
we thought it would but it did end up
being
pretty polarizing some people really
liked it and some people really don't in
a blog post on wednesday youtube
announced they were removing the dislike
character to quote ensure that youtube
promotes respectful interactions between
viewers and creators the term of art
apparently is brigading so
these are down voting groups and so they
will
like on twitter the ratio and concept
ratio and concept slightly different
i'll explain in a second um
you can hit uh the dislike button here's
what it's gonna look like if you're
watching the show uh so you'll see a
number next to the votes up so everybody
gets a medal everybody gets a cookie
everybody you know participates but you
don't share with the public what the
audience actually thought of your video
i kind of like this um i do think that
the uh brigading that's an issue on the
margins and people will brigade for
other reasons
you know it's kind of part of the price
you pay for allowing people to say what
they think and you know the comments can
be particularly difficult on people
especially if people are attacking other
people about their appearance or
whatever and so they've removed some of
those comments and i noticed that
commenting is getting better on youtube
i think they're making it harder to make
burner accounts or easier to report or
maybe they're pretty light trigger on
removing a comment when it is reported
and it has some negative sentiment
doesn't come as much of a surprise in
march youtube announced a small
experiment where they hid dislike counts
on select videos and uh here is what
youtube's head creator liaison
matt koval had to say
on the dislike button it's a 50 second
clip and i will see you on the side i've
always thought seeing the number of
dislikes on a video helps us know as
viewers if it's a good video or not if
it's a helpful tutorial or not or if
what a creator is is saying in their
video is generally agreed with
or not but unfortunately research teams
at youtube have found there's this whole
other use for disliking a video that i
had never experienced as a creator and
you may not have either
apparently groups of viewers are
targeting a video's dislike button to
drive up the count turning it into
something like a a game with a visible
scoreboard
and it's usually just because they don't
like the creator or what they stand for
that's a big problem when half of
youtube's mission is to give everyone a
voice
okay there you have it certainly good
intent uh there might be second order
impacts here that are not good i i have
to say i like a little rough and tumble
i like the dislike button because i feel
as content creators you know if you want
to evolve you do need to get some
negative feedback in order to grow and
it's tough but you know if you're a
comedian you have to go play comedy
clubs where nobody knows you and it's a
different group of people and you're at
a disadvantage it's not your friends and
your fans in the audience and you're
going to bomb and that helps you sharpen
your knife right if you
bomb you you really get motivated to
make better content if you get booed off
the stage you know like that's what this
the thumbs down button is it's kind of a
way for the audience to boo you i don't
know it feels soft to me i gotta be
honest i don't like it i like being able
to vote something down if i disagree
with it or i think the content is lame i
would have done this as you can opt into
this so if you have a political channel
you can turn off uh likes and dislikes
on it right i guess or turn off view
counts um but youtube makes these
decisions generally in what's in their
best interest and what's you know in
alignment with their mission and their
mission is
uh to grow the creator base and and you
know allow people to express themselves
so i kind of think like this is the best
decision for them i don't think it's the
best decision for the users so if i was
thinking about the users i like the
users having this ability to give like a
massive
vote of no confidence i would like to
see this on other platforms as well i
like the vote down apparently twitter is
uh doing vote downs the way you do uh
this kind of voting down mechanism and
you show your discontent with the
content is by ratioing it so you don't
you don't star it you don't retweet it
but you do comment so what that means is
people don't want to amplify this tweet
they're like yeah this is not worthy of
me sharing with my audience or me
hitting the like button or harding it
but i will respond to you and tell you
how bad your tweet is and so
i do have like david sax's like
right-wing folks will come to me and
ratio me and like they love ratioing you
know the the wacky all
right people who
hang on peter thiel and david sachs's
every word and then on the other side
like the aoc
liberal
you know chesa boudin people in san
francisco they're all like
crazy socialist like they love to ratio
you and it's it's just gross um but but
it's it's a good feedback mechanism uh i
think and so i like it but the world is
soft i mean somebody just said in the
chat room but i think it'd be good to
have a vote down i would love to see the
vote downs on
twitter i'd love to have a list of the
most voted down
by the way i think that if these are
gangs doing these voting down rings it's
very easy for youtube to figure that out
all they have to do is look at all the
voting down rings and look at the users
who voted something down like in a gang
kind of way and then they could see that
they have a pattern of also doing that
to other videos and then you just take
all their votes and you do what's called
in the industry neutering them
clip clip they have no impact they don't
count they think that their votes are
counting because when they go to the
site and they click the down vote it
goes up for them and it shows them their
vote but it doesn't actually register it
so you you kind of
it's like the madman technique you
basically make people lose their minds
because they're commenting and they're
voting something up or down
and they see it on their version of the
website so they actually see their you
know toxic comment they see the vote up
and down but the public doesn't see it
so they would have to open another
browser to see that their stuff isn't up
there and so they might go for a year
you know harassing somebody on a blog or
on youtube or whatever and they think
that their message is getting through
and nobody's seeing it it's like they're
yelling into the void it's like sending
zod into the forbidden whatever the
glass was and superman too uh all right
next up on the program david benaham who
is doing some really cool gaming and nft
and avatar work for the metaverse stick
with us
if you've read business news over the
past few weeks the only thing you can
say is wow craziness in the markets
keeps things interesting but when it
comes to your finances sometimes less is
more and diversification is important
according to masterworks now you can add
contemporary art to your portfolio with
masterworks masterworks dot io has
revolutionized the art market by
allowing any investor to buy shares of
multi-million dollar paintings just like
buying stock in a company they already
have over 250 million in aum that's
assets under management and
congratulations to the massworks team on
becoming new york's newest fintech
unicorn ah man i should have went my big
on that one okay so here's your call to
action you can skip the wait list and
get access today by going to masterworks
dot io
slash twist that's masterworks dot io
slash twist and i've bought some shares
and paintings there i think it's a very
cool service